I have to film this before I decide that
this is stupid and they don't want to
film it anymore no hi my name is grace
Helbig did not know now you know your
life is different now
very jet lag but you probably couldn't
tell because this is how I normally like
I'm jet lag because I just got back from
VidCon Australia it was super fun all of
you guys that came and said hi we're
wonderful and other sentiments that are
genuine and etc why was that ordered
room service from the hotel and that's
normal because I'm literally Rapunzel if
she like voluntarily asked to stay in
that Tower
you're gonna bring me food you're gonna
clean out my squalor gotta take a lot
for me to come down from here you're
gonna have to threaten to climb my hair
and then I'll be like I'll meet you in
the lobby but then one room service is
about to come I realized I was in my
deepest like scum phase there's hungover
and then there's just like wooly settled
in you're scum phase and I was in that
dough I panic try and like make myself
presentable to the room-service person
and this is not a new scenario for me to
be in me rushing around to create the
illusion that I am much more capable
human being I have an unhealthy
relationship with the people that work
for delivery services I'm talking about
like uber AIDS I'm talking about
postmates I'm talking about room service
when I'm ordering from any of these
things I'm at my lowest low my scummiest
gun could not be bothered to drive ten
minutes to get an avocado I gotta get it
on Amazon Prime now which I've done now
proud but it was available and they were
right and I made guacamole except I
didn't have cilantro because they didn't
have cilantro on Amazon Prime now and I
was like upset that they didn't have it
and I had to get upset at myself for
what am I doing with my life
so but today I just wanted to talk about
and maybe this is something you struggle
with you the idea trying to impress a
delivery person when you know you can't
do it but still I'm gonna try they told
Rudi they couldn't play football and he
did it this is not a relevant analogy if
I'm wondering from a place like
postmates which side note I can't do
because I've been locked out of that app
for like two years because they thought
I had credit-card fraud and then they
won't let me back I've gotten new credit
cards I've tried to re-register
let me back this is sad to be upset
about when you order from these websites
you're either lazy scared or having a
hard time when I'm ordering from one of
these websites I'm not in my best shape
I'm not on my a-game I am NOT in good
form I am in fact in bad form I'm
ordering from these sites because I want
to stay in my nest of depression and
just be swallowed whole by my house of
sadness but I don't want them to know
that for whatever reason I convinced
myself that I can convince them that I'm
doing great so I changed myself from
this to looking like I'm going to adult
prom when they show up sometimes I want
them to think that maybe I was playing
my cello for too long and that's what I
couldn't possibly make myself these five
different types of quesadillas or maybe
time slipped away because I was so busy
studying my third language on rosetta
stone and I couldn't possibly go to the
store and pick up 12 pounds of toilet
paper or maybe I was just too swamped
planning so many charity events saving
children and animals in the world that I
couldn't possibly get to a convenience
store buy my plan B beans beans plan
beans but then I thought to myself they
know they know a delivery person knows
they have a job because we are bad and
terrible and lazy no one's calling to
order that much toilet paper Taco Bell
or plan B if they've got their life
together and if they are successful they
should go to a doctor so maybe I should
stop making myself look like I'm going
to a red carpet premiere when room
service shows up to my hotel room maybe
I should stop turn the shower on to
pretend that I ordered those four
martinis for two people instead of and
maybe I should stop screaming you know
now Bay after they've dropped it off
maybe I should accept that they're not
gonna judge me because I'm not judging
them maybe the world would be a little
bit better if we believed in each other
accept it each other respected each
other no I'm still gonna be ordering
Plan B off of Amazon Prime down I'm
still gonna look like Carmen Sandiego
when you show up and I'm still gonna
pretend that my cousin was staying with
me and she had a wild night and I'm just
being a good cousin in order in this for
I don't know just seep in my shelter of
sadness hunker down in my high anxiety
home Nestle and my no judgment emptiness
it's like I'm doomsday prepping for just
my emotions of the day